c'est une tradition au sein de
l'entreprise colas l'engagement pour une
route plus sûre depuis 1997 la filiale
de bouygues signent une charte avec la
délégation interministérielle à la
sécurité routière plus de 400
collaborateurs de colas désigné relais
sécurité routière sont engagés sur ce
sujet nous on a 60 personnes en groupe
les soixante mille personnes sont en
contact permanent avec ce que nous
faisons en sécurité au caire et c'est
quelque chose qui s'arrête pas quand
petit le travail quand ils reviennent
chez eux dans leur vie privée ils
continuent à avoir ce réflexe et c'est
comme ça qu'on peut créer une sorte
d'effet boule de neige pour harry
arriver à améliorer la sécurité routière
partout limitée aux cas d'urgence les
conversations téléphoniques rappelé
l'exigence du port de la ceinture ou
encore le bridage de la vitesse des
véhicules des actions pour sensibiliser
les collaborateurs de colas aujourd'hui
la délégation interministérielle à la
sécurité routière a déjà signé avec 1800
entreprises représentant plus de 3
millions de salariés l'insécurité
routière c'est la première cause de
mortalité au travail et ensuite parce
que eh bien justement les accidents liés
au travail correspondent à une part
importante des accidents sur la route
spécialisée dans les infrastructures
routières les équipes recherche et
développement de colas ont pu présenter
les dernières innovations en lien avec
la sécurité routière notamment la
solution de marquage au sol lumineuse ce
qui paraît particulièrement utile
notamment pour protéger des usagers
vulnérables dans le cadre de passage
piéton ou de voix cyclistes notamment
donc nous allons regarder avec colle
assez bien ce qu'il propose avec son
engagement pour la sécurité routière
colas a réduit de plus de 75% le taux de
fréquence des accidents routiers
professionnels